hallo deutsch schule punkt ch hören und
nachsprechen
[Musik]
lektion 33 hört zu und spricht nach
trinken trinken
er trinkt einen tee er trinkt einen tee
er hat einen tee getrunken
singen singen er singt ein lied
er singt ein lied
er hat ein lied gesungen
er hat
lied gesungen finden finden
er findet seinen schlüssel nicht
er hat seinen schlüssel nicht gefunden
fahren fahren
er fährt nach hause
er ist nach hause gefahren
waschen war
er wäscht die kleider
er hat die kleider gewaschen
er hat die kleider gewaschen schlafen
er schläft gut
er schläft gut er hat gut geschlafen
er hat gut geschlafen schließen
schließen
er schließt die tür
er hat die tür geschlossen
schwimmen schwimmen
er schwimmt im hallenbad
er ist im hallenbad geschwommen
er ist im hallenbad geschwommen brechen
brechen
er bricht
seinen arm er bricht sich seinen arm
er hat sich seinen arm gebrochen
er hat sich seinen arm gebrochen bleiben
bleiben
ihr bleibt zu hause
er bleibt zu hause
er ist zu hause geblieben
er ist zu hause geblieben schreiben
schreiben
er schreibt eine e mail
er hat
e mail geschrieben er hatte
e mail geschrieben scheinen scheine
die sonne scheint die sonne scheint die
sonne hat geschienen
die sonne hat geschienen streiten
streiten er streitet mit seiner
schwester er streitet mit seiner
schwester er hat mit seiner schwester
gestritten
er hat mit sein
schwester gestritten reiten reiten
er reitet auf dem pferd er reitet auf
dem zerrt er ist auf dem pferd geritten
er ist auf dem pferd geritten schneiden
schneiden der friseur schneidet meine
haare
er schneidet meine haare der friseur hat
meine haare geschnitten
der friseur hat meine haare geschnitten
wann bist du geboren bist du geboren
ich bin am 12 juni 1980 geboren
ich bin 2002 in die schweiz gekommen
2002 bin ich in die schweiz gekommen
mein großvater ist letztes jahr
gestorben
letz
er ist mein großvater gestorben letztes
jahr ist mein großvater gestorben
mein großvater ist vor einem jahr
gestorben
vor einem jahr ist mein großvater
nicht vergessen dieses video zu liken zu
kommentieren um zu teilen nicht
vergessen dieses video zu liken zu
kommentieren und zu teilen möchtest du
doch weitere videos sehen dann abonniere
unseren kanal jeden sonntag ein neues
video
möchtest du noch weitere videos sehen
dann abonniere unseren kanal jeden
sonntag ein neues video